bonsoir rail est chez ibi l'économie
française un petit peu en perte de
vitesse en afrique au profit d'autres
pays comme par exemple la chine ce
sommet certes mondiale mais à
l'initiative de la france ce n'est pas
un moyen pour l'hexagone de servir ses
intérêts financiers
le pansement
je le pense pas parce que les liens
entre le la france et l'afrique et
notamment depuis que le président
emmanuel macron est arrivé au pouvoir on
sait qu'il a fait de l'afrique un
partenaire privilégié et que surtout il
a un regard qui est assez nouveau de sur
les relations que doivent avoir la
france avec l'afrique avec la nécessité
de soutenir l'économie africaine de
soutenir sa jeunesse qu'est la véritable
richesse du continent
donc le fait que la france soit
l'initiative d'un d'un événement
international et d'un sommet aussi
important pour la relance économique
africaine je ne pense pas que ce soit
une très mauvaise idée est au contraire
c'est ça permet justement d'impulser une
nouvelle dynamique pour un continent qui
en a bien besoin pour relancer
l'économie africaine vaste programme le
projet de s'annonce titanesque vu la
taille et les disparités du continent à
quoi faut-il s'attendre pour vous il ya
une forme d'efficacité on est obligé la
crise la crise sanitaire que nous avons
vécu a vraiment marqué à la fois les
esprits mais surtout à marquer notre
économie la france était très durement
frappé l'afrique également je rappelle
juste les chiffres qui ont été dits
d'ailleurs lors du reportage
cette crise va entraîner l'extrême
pauvreté de 39 millions dhs africaine et
d'africains et si nous faisons rien ça
va empirer
donc le fait d'organiser une initiative
par la voix de multi latérale en
associant des pays de tout le continent
des pays du maghreb des pays d'afrique
de l'ouest deprick d'afrique centrale ou
du sud avec aussi et c'est ça qui est
important
des grandes institutions financières et
bancaires internationales
c'est la volonté vraiment d'impulser
quelque chose de nouveau donc oui c'est
très important je rappelle que cette
crise sanitaire que nous avons vécue et
que nous continuons de vivre aura un
impact a déjà un impact économique
social et surtout bien sûr sanitaire
donc j'ose espérer que de ce sommet va
en ressortir à la fois bien sûr des
mesures concrètes comme la réduction ou
l'effacement de la dette c'est ce qui
est d'ailleurs puisque je suis président
d'une association qui oeuvre à
promouvoir la coopération d'amitié entre
la france et la tunisie
je salue d'ailleurs la déclaration qui a
effectué le le président de la
république tunisienne dans ce qu'il
disait que l'endettement reprendre l'un
des principaux obstacles à la relance
économique
je le pense aussi donc j'ose espérer que
deux ce sommet ressortira des
propositions concrètes permettant à la
fois de réduire la dette de certains
pays africains voire de ceux qui en ont
vraiment besoin
mais en guerre mais entendent impulser
une nouvelle dynamique permettant de
reprise économique significative du
continent africain vous le dites à
l'afrique avec un des chiffres
impressionnants liés à l'actif sanitaire
et pourtant le continent a été
relativement épargné par la crise du coc
vite comment expliquer bas effectivement
quand on quand on regarde les chiffres
il ya eu 130 mille morts même si même si
on considère que le continent était a
été épargné c'est quand même 130 mille
victimes et on ne peut avoir que que que
penser et et regrets pour les familles
qui ont été endeuillées je pense que le
pays et que le continent pardon à a
plutôt bien résisté parce que beaucoup
de mesures ont été prises quasiment
immédiatement à savoir le le confinement
pour bon nombre de pays
donc des mesures très rapides très
concrètes ont été prises et je pense que
c'est aussi ça qui a sauvé quelque part
l'afrique
d'une on va dire d'un cataclysme
sanitaires pour autant pour autant c'est
aussi leur petit cache la forêt parce
que même s'il ya eu très peu de victimes
en afrique mais des victimes quand même
il n'en demeure pas moins que ça a mis
en exergue
les inégalités d'accès à des soins de
qualité mais surtout mais surtout
d'avoir des structures des
infrastructures médicales de qualité et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ose
espérer que de ce sommet c'est un appel
d'ailleurs que je lance à l'ensemble des
chefs d'état d'afrique et au président
de la république emmanuel macron c'est
de faire en sorte que les
investissements qui vont être décidée je
l'espère pour l'afrique permettent
également de d'investir massivement dans
le comment dirais-je dans le secteur
sanitaire mais également dans
l'éducation parce qu'on voit bien que
abbaye confiné c'était aussi
malheureusement et en particulier pour
l'afrique
une coupure entre les enfants et le
monde éducatif donc la nécessité
d'investir la dent sur c'est sur ces
deux thématiques et sur ces deux
domaines
justement qui les investissements disent
beaucoup attiré des investisseurs privés
dans ces pays africains c'est en tout
cas ce qu'estime emmanuel macron ça
serait l'une des solutions pour relancer
la croissance économique africaine cela
vous paraît dans le domaine du possible
oui ça peut être possible mais il faut
aussi investir dans les tpe pme qui sont
présentes en afrique parce que
l'économie la relance économique du
continent se fera bien sûr par une aide
significative de la part de des
bailleurs internationaux qui je l'espère
joueront leur le rôle pleinement mais il
faut aussi soutenir ceux qui sont les
acteurs le poumon mail économique du
continent
les tpe les pme qui investissent
massivement et qui de leur énergie de
leur temps cette jeunesse comme disait
le président de la république c'est une
jeunesse créative dynamique pour
l'exemple de la tunisie pays que je
connais le mieux mais c'est pareil en
côte d'ivoire c'est pareil au mali c'est
pareil en afrique du sud c'est pareil en
république démocratique du congo
l'afrique
elle a une richesse qui est sage ce qui
est sa jeunesse il faut investir avec
elle et ça me permet elle votre question
me permet également d'avoir cette la
réflexion suivante et je dirais même la
proposition suivante je pense que dans
ce type de sommets qui encore une fois
est en sus un sommet qu'il faut saluer
parce qu'on met en valeur le
multilatéralisme
je pense qu'il faut aussi promouvoir ce
que j'appelle moi le multilatéralisme
civile c'est à dire faire en sorte d'
associer avec ses chefs d'état
gouvernement les acteurs de la société
civile ceux qui font l'économie
africaine mais également ceux qui
s'investissent pour promouvoir
je dirai ce que j'appelle également
diplomatie associative c'est à dire
comment dirais-je associer tous les
talents de la société civile des
fondations des entreprises et faire en
sorte d'apporter aux côtés des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement des solutions
concrètes pour le continent donc oui à
ce sommet des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement mais je pense qu'il faut
élargir aux acteurs économiques du
continent parce qu'ils connaissent
parfaitement
je dirais le le les problématiques et la
nécessité de d'investissement et surtout
la nécessité de 2 comment dirais-je de
sortir de la crise dans laquelle nous
vivons
mais je pense également qu'il faut
associer les autres acteurs de la
société civile qui sont tout aussi
engagée pour l'afrique est qui et qui
aime aussi ce continent parce que c'est
aussi le nôtre
vous parliez de l'annulation de la dette
en africains pour laquelle vous vous
plaidez l'année dernière d'ailleurs à
emmanuel macron également pour cette
annulation aujourd'hui le président
français parlerait plutôt d'un new deal
c'est un revirement vous vous
l'expliquez comment ben c'est peut-être
aussi la volonté de certains et pays
d'afrique parce que quand vous regardez
le continent vous avez effectivement
certains pays qui nécessite à ce qu'il y
ait un effacement de la dette
vous avez pris le cas tout à l'heure il
me semble delà de la somalie je crois et
vous avez d'autres d'autres pays qui eux
nécessitent ou réclame uniquement une
réduction massive de la dette ça dépend
fonction des pays certains pays s'en
sont mieux sorties que d'autres aussi
bien économiquement que financièrement
donc à chaque pays sa propre blog sa
propre problématique pardonnez-moi mais
le j'ai envie de dire que le point
commun de tout ça c'est que
économiquement ya besoin d'avoir d'avoir
une relance et donc quand vous prenez un
pays extrêmement pauvre comme le soudan
s'est pas forcément la même
problématique que si vous prenez un pays
comme
la côte d'ivoire ou bien je la
république démocratique du congo qui ont
des ressources naturelles qui leur
permet malgré tout de faire face aux
difficultés pour que thil une réduction
massive
oui et qui est un effacement pour
d'autres pays oui également merci
riadh fehri d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france est à noter que
les participants au sommet sur les
économies africaines ont demandé
officiellement la levée des brevets sur
les vaccins ce soir c'est emmanuel de
macron lui-même qu'il annonce